foreign
just a few items before we have our
hearing on bill 475.
um because of the snowstorm everybody's
here today all the Committees so we got
a leftover room I have a pothole under
this chair it's actually there is the
the splash plate does not have any
screws left in it we don't have a screw
loose we have no screws so
um
the other thing is another committee is
coming in this afternoon so we were told
we got to be out of here by 12 30. so
when it comes to debates discussions and
so on uh say your peace but make a brief
one bill is a hearing on 475 that's
scheduled for 9 30. the rest are exacts
which are scheduled for 10 15 and
onwards if you write the blurb
we have to have it before you leave
because it has to be passed along for
committee services to deal with so
that doesn't mean everybody be bashful
and nobody volunteered to do it it just
means Say Say What You Need to Say
and turn it in I have to edit it there's
a few things that they don't like like
it is a well-known fact that and
everybody else is a who disagrees
with me I have to change that
I might believe it but I can't say it
supposed to write idiot
you're pushing no maybe not you really
you know what I mean you have to say we
believe that okay
and just one final thing when we do exec
some bills
and I say something like the motion
before us is itl is moved by so and so
and second and by so and so at that
point if you're not in the room you
don't get to vote that's when the
question is called so you'll sense the
rhythm of it and very often if you just
gotta go out the best time to do is
right after we have just finished
executing because it'll take a little
while in discussion before we get to the
next vote so that's that's probably the
best time to leave if you have to any
questions on procedures for today
okay
I open the hearing on House Bill
475 and is representative post here to
I knew that but I have to say that
you've already passed the first test you
turned the mic on I'm getting used to it
I know I've been here seven years and
I'm getting used to it
so good morning I thank you
um Mr chairman and the committee I am
here on HB uh 475 for the record I am
Lisa post from linebro
and I am Prime sponsor on this bill
um this bill establishes a right to
submit evidence and testimony in Family
Court proceedings it provides family
with an equal opportunity to present
their evidence and testimony to the
Circuit Court Family Division
our state rules of civil procedures lays
down The rules that should be followed
by the state district court and civil
actions
however for many for many of the family
court
it is not following these civil
procedures that allows both parties to
submit evidence and testimony I ask how
is the court making these life-altering
decisions for families when they are
only allowing one party to submit
evidence or testimony
with all the concerns in the Circuit
Court division as legislators we have an
obligation to the people to put good
language in place and with the passage
of this bill our families will have an
opportunity that is fair balanced for
both parties and will have the potential
for reduced Stress and Anxiety on
families and the court I ask that you
vote HB 475
ought to pass in the event you don't
pass it I would like to ask that it be
retained
any questions representative Raymond
uh thank you Mr chairman
have you done something to it yes I was
thinking this might be more effective
I'm excited about it well done sorry
everyone I'm usually in the corner where
he cannot see me and I have to like wave
anyways thank you so much for being here
this morning representative post
um hopefully you had a safe drive and
um I wondered if you could explain a
little bit more about the current
process in Family Division I know a lot
about how dcyf cases work but I don't
know as much about divorces and so when
I read your bill I thought well can't
people submit evidence so if you could
just take a couple minutes to walk us
through who can and who can't submit
evidence that would be helpful to me
so the issue at hand is sometimes they
will take evidence for one and not the
other and so parties are disenfranchised
when they don't have the ability to have
that heard uh so this the the change in
this is um
right here enact establishing evidence
and testimony in Family Court
proceedings
um and let me go to this part where
um
the person has a right to present
evidence where they did not have a right
before so this is how it changes that
um so giving them the right
allows both parties to
um submit that information
and they're also in this
um
on the the back of this um this right
this right shall not be limited by the
presiding judge magistrate or marital
master or by the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence or the rules of the Circuit
Court Family Division this court shall
note in the record of the proceedings
any evidence not admitted into the
record including the specific evidence
or testimony not admitted and the reason
why it was not admitted this is this is
a way to show if they haven't accepted
it why
um so for for many people that are
struggling to present evidence it
becomes a big frustration and and
it it is not fair they need to look at
both sides to both people to make sure
that they have the evidence they need to
make the decisions that are best for the
child
and best for the family so I hope that
answers your question
thank you Mr uh Vice chairman um
so what about evidence that is generally
would be inadmissible
is there because this is taking away the
discretion of the presiding judge
so
how would we protect against just though
I don't think it takes it away from the
presiding judge because if he decides
not to do it all he has to do is list
why he's not doing it well it's like
this right shall not be limited by the
in the in the bill
or marital master or by the New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence right it
does say that but it does give them it
does give them an opportunity in this
bill where it says the court shall note
in the record of the proceedings any
evidence not admitted into the record
including the specific evidence or
testimony not admit not admitted and the
reason why it is uh was not admitted so
I believe that is the opening for the
judges to be abled or the magistrate in
order to be able to do that they just
have to record it but it but it is our
hope that they will accept as much
evidence as they possibly can because
how can how can they really make a
decision when one side is allowed to
present and the other is not
representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here today
second that I
I am concerned about the language and
and basically what she said I I don't
see how these two don't conflict because
when we're telling a judge you shall not
but then we say but if you do right then
you have to do this I don't understand
how they are not in complete conflict or
which one overrules the other
if we can if we need another word to
change it but because they are not doing
it they are not following it that's why
we chose the word shall but but we put
in there that I I hate to say it it's an
out
um because I don't really want that to
be an out but in in cases where there's
a reason for it a a reason why they are
not accepting it I I think that gives
the judge the ability to know that they
should take it if
if there's a reason not to right
um and if there is a good reason they
have the ability to make this choice of
putting it in the record representative
post is somewhat of a linguist and
basically a word snob
um I would have liked unless on the
occasion when that this is what is the
default
it's assumed don't assume when you can
State and what I'm going to suggest is
after the hearing is over you run I want
to keep this one from being exact right
away okay to give you a chance to go
down to OLS and make some changes not
just this one but any other changes that
may suggest themselves during this
hearing okay and then and sit there with
them while they do it and let them know
they have please until noon and then
once it is approved by them you have to
approve it and then you have to let
committee Services know that you've done
it so they will produce the copy so the
copies will come down here you miss one
of those steps this doesn't happen Okay
okay so you you make the changes you
like you go to OLS they show you their
work product on Deadline you if you
approve it you approve it and you tell
them specifically intentionally send it
to committee services run up to the
fourth floor and wait for them to print
it out bring the copies down here and
then we can exec it that doesn't
guarantee we'll pass it but right now I
think the word confusion in here is
enough to keep us from doing that
so unless where do you want that to be
changed that's your problem it has to
say in effect
generally speaking you must and if you
do not you have to do that it has to be
one of those has to be logical
representative DeSimone
Gwen I am reading this bill I am reading
and you being a linguist will I hope
understand I'd like you to correct me if
I'm
on not understanding the bill please
the bill is about
um
the news section is a right to present
evidence and every person who goes into
the
courtroom has a right to present the
evidence and
so forth that goes on that the judge or
magistrate shall accept the evidence
is that correct
it says this right shall not be limited
right
okay thank you follow up please follow
up thank you Mr chair and thank you
again for the follow-up
but to correct the um misunderstandings
the court shall note
in the record of proceedings any
evidence not admitted
into the record is that correct
I believe so because if if the court is
not taking it
they have to record that they have not
taken one final follow-up one more thank
you so is it true that what you're
saying is
Mr Miss Ms judge or magistrate
these people have a right to present
but if you don't accept it into the
record you shall make a record as to why
is that the difference in the two
paragraphs
is that the difference yes I believe it
is present and the
not putting it in the record is that
true
representative long
thank you Mr chairman
uh thank you representative uh just
further note if you're going to do an
amendment uh Judiciary historically we
start in January of the following year
so you may want to look at the effective
date so we want to do 2024. I believe
it's January of yes 2024. okay we will
do that uh and a question earlier you
said that uh oftentimes
um that the judge takes evidence from
one party and not the other is that on
the same issue do you know
um like if it's issue a and uh I pers
the judge accepts my evidence but my ex
he doesn't accept any evidence from her
on is it on the same issue or is it just
under different issues where they'll
accept from one party and not you know
consistently from the other party
I believe that to be true where it comes
from one and not the other and that's
the real part of okay so not necessarily
why we need this to get in okay great
thank you
anyone else with a question for
representative post the prime sponsor
he's saying none thank you so much the
chair now recognizes representative
ulery he says he has a caucus at 10
o'clock
so
you know it's a tough burden to be
thank you my name is Jordan ulery
representing Hillsborough 13 which is
Hudson New Hampshire I'm a co-sponsor on
this bill some of the questions that
have been brought up are appropriate
but it's the questions that come up to
the representatives across the state
Regarding why wasn't I allowed
well a lot of people don't understand
how the court system operates
disconnected system of common law where
you can say anything you want in
statutory law which says that you have
to follow this set of rules
when you're dealing with family law yes
I think you guys know
you have to explain to everybody in a
good fashion in a well so they
understand it if this person
person a cannot accept
or cannot present what they feel is
evidence and then the judge just says no
because the judge knows what the process
is and what's going on the opposition
may have an attorney and knows what the
pro what the situation is but the other
party is sitting there going why not
he presented his financials I'm
presenting financial information but it
wasn't the wrong format it was from a
different source
so by allowing them to present the
information
and then get an explanation as to why
not
both parties in a very emotional very
sensitive situation get to understand
what happened and how to correct it
of course
as I'm sure the member from the bar
association will quote Abraham Lincoln
had perhaps the best quote regarding an
attorney and attending Court Pro Se
the person who represents himself has a
fool for a client
but not everybody can afford even though
there are alternative payment sources so
I would urge passage of this uh the
recommendation of language of course the
bills and the committee's control they
can handle it any way they want you do
have retention available for you it's
not uh something it's not part of the
budget so we don't have to worry about
that kind of activity but
um
this is the type of thing that sits well
with a section of the population that
goes before court and has essentially
some of their parental rights
taken from them and they need to know
why
I've been around here long enough
couple of you more than a couple a few
of you have been around long enough to
know that we've had impeachment cases
come before the general court and the
reason for the impeachment
or the cost for the impeachment was
precisely this a lack of understanding a
being discriminated against
of course feelings are each individuals
and you have no control over them are of
or other people's feelings but you can
make it better and that's what this bill
does
and
I'm just going down the hall so I'll
take one or two questions if there are
any
I just let the representative know and
everyone else that on the last Tuesday
of the month in the afternoon somewhere
in the building we will be having a
continuing education program led by the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court the
retired Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court attorney had and
Judge David King whose administrative
Justice of the Circuit Court to answer
these questions that a lot of people
don't know the answers to and to receive
questions from anybody that comes and
you are invited yeah I appreciate that
very much sir uh going back to the
previous activities it's not this body
that needs that information but it's the
general population understood and we
hope that this would be but the
beginning of an education process not
just for the house but for the general
population I think it would help members
of the House some of whom oftentimes
seeing no questions for the
representative have fun in your exact
session and now the chair recognizes The
Honorable Betty gay and alumna of this
body
thank you very much for taking my my
testimony it's extremely simple
I think ever since the Magna Carta and
they recognize that we need rights
one of the rights that we all assume is
that when you're in court you have a
right to present evidence to support
your case especially something that
would protect you and so I brought a
current copy I'll hand it out the
current copy of rule 2.2 rules of the
Circuit Court of the State of New
Hampshire Family Division
rule 2.2 application of New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence the New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence do not apply to the
actions listed above
however the coordinates in its
discretion May utilize the New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence to enhance the
predictable orderly fair and reliable
presentation of evidence
I guess I was shocked as are the people
that I tell that this law is needed this
because we all assume that you always
have the Rules of Evidence to support
you and that of course if the judge
determines that it's not applicable
so I really appreciate all the
wordsmithing that y'all have done to
show that it's the right to present
evidence you're not overturning uh the
judge's right to not accept it so I
really do appreciate your fine-tuning
the wording but I do hope that you
that you would really want the right to
present evidence to support your case
the reason for this I I became aware
of the lack of this protection when I
met a couple of people who
um or refused an evidentiary hearing
they had the evidence to support it and
it was of course critical to their case
it was custody of their child
um and the judge
simply said I've already made up my mind
I don't need evidence
so this just levels the playing field
makes everybody have the right that they
would have in Criminal Court
to uh have it in Family Court would you
take any questions
sure
but I don't see any so thank you for
your testimony thank you chair
that would be of the pink card Gale
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today for the record my name
is Gail drobat I reside in Amherst New
Hampshire
and as our elected policy makers you
have the greatest ability to reform and
create laws to better protect the
citizens of New Hampshire and the branch
of government that supersedes judiciary
I respectfully pray each of you support
this important bill I am submitting oral
Unwritten testimony and full support of
HB 475 a much-needed law to better
protect New Hampshire Children and
Families a rule a judge's unfettered
abusive discretion and Performing Above
the Law and not below the law is harming
New Hampshire Children and Families
the ability for a circuit court judge to
suppress evidence deprives New Hampshire
families their right to be heard and to
make an accurate record
the Circuit Court Family divisions are
making life-altering decisions for
children in the suppression of evidence
and the refusal to acknowledge or admit
evidence has detrimental consequences
to the outcomes for New Hampshire
children
judicial officers and officers of the
Court take an oath to uphold the U.S
Constitution New Hampshire Constitution
and New Hampshire State Statute laws
Each of which supersedes the New
Hampshire rules of the Circuit Court
such as New Hampshire Circuit Court rule
2.2 application of New Hampshire Rules
of Evidence state in part the New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence do not apply
it is well beyond time that we bring the
family law system within the scope and
control of the United States
Constitution the New Hampshire
Constitution and clear and concise State
Statute laws that judicial offices are
mandated to follow
a litigant should not have to file a
federal lawsuit to right the wrongs of
the New Hampshire judiciary
thank you for your dedication to your
role as elected policy makers to bring
this New Hampshire law into
constitutional compliance thank you for
your testimony would you take any
questions
seeing none thank you so much
chair recognizes Attorney Richard head
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch we do not support
this bill as written and I wanted to
briefly explain why that is
first off I just want to remind
everybody what we're talking about when
we're talking Family Division it
references Family Court we don't have a
family court per se we have Family
Division within the Circuit Court
Family Division within the Circuit Court
does not just handle marital cases it
handles domestic violence guardianship
of minors juvenile delinquency
termination of parental rights abuse and
neglect cases
children in need of services adoption in
addition to marital cases so we're not
simply talking about
marital cases we're not simply talking
about
divorces we're talking about a wide
range of cases when we're talking about
so what this bill would do in the first
sentence is provide that
parties have the right to present
evidence and testimony and the second
sentence is a absolute prohibition on
any limitation so that presiding judge
is not allowed to limit the authority
The Rules of Evidence would not be
allowed to limit that power and the
rules would not be allowed to limit that
power
and and similar to what you know we've
seen it in hearings before this
committee at times the presiding or the
the chairman
um
informs a a witness that they are not
speaking about the topic of the bill
that they've gone off topic and and ask
that person to stay with the topic of
the bill
sometimes the chairman will limit the
amount of time a person has to testify
because you have 20 other bills behind
that bill or there are a lot of people
that are coming to testify it's not that
much different in a courtroom we there
is going to be a particular issue that
is before the judge on that day and the
judge nears needs to hear evidence and
testimony that is relevant to that
particular issue and if it goes off of
that issue or the information that's
trying to be presented is is on a
different issue maybe except for a
different hearing or just not what is
before the judge and what the judge has
to decide on that particular day for
that hearing the judge may try to limit
that that testimony and information
in this bill would essentially
turn over control of the courtroom
and how courtroom proceedings are
handled and managed to the parties
instead of the judge and I bring up the
word filibuster because there's nothing
in this bill that would limit a party in
terms of time in terms of scope in terms
of Topic in terms of any information
that is being presented or the number of
witnesses that are being presented or
what they're going to talk about you
know somebody may decide I have to read
every word of my three volume file from
beginning to end because I as a party
think that is important for the judge
because I don't think the Judge has read
the file it might take a day and a half
this would eliminate the judge's ability
to control
and and the reality is the judges simply
has to be able to
control evidence to be what's relevant
to the subject that is before that judge
um The Rules of Evidence applied
generally but do not apply strictly
um and the reason for that is is in the
vast majority especially over talking
about marital vast majority of parties
are not represented by Council and most
parties have do not know the rules of
evidence they have gone to law school
they haven't studied them or if they
read them they may not understand it you
know a basic rule of evidence is hearsay
everyone knows what hearsay is hearsay
and I would have to read it again
because it's been a little while but
hearsay is an out of court statement
being made or being introduced for the
truth of the matter asserted so you know
does everybody know what the truth of
the matter asserted means in terms of of
hearsay does a party who's never sort of
been in court before know what that
means does a party who has
um limited educational background know
what that means does a person with
mental health issues know what that
means probably not so if we were to
apply the Rules of Evidence strictly
we're actually probably treating parties
unfairly especially if one understands
it and the other doesn't so you you sort
of have to be able to use those as
guidelines we want relevant information
we want timely information but we also
have 10 other cases behind that that
case and and if somebody were to
essentially consume the day time because
they think information is is important
and relevant
other parties are not going to have
their case heard because there's only so
many hours in a day so you have seven
and a half hours if they go beyond their
a lot of time and they essentially spend
the day there's nothing the judge can do
to control that that
uh introduce an introduction of evidence
or testimony it can also be done used in
a way to abuse the other party so if
there is a disparity of wealth if
there's a disparity of time availability
somebody who knows that and simply wants
to punish the other side can say I'm
going to spend the next day and I'm
going to make this person come back and
miss work tomorrow because I can and
because the judge can't stop me
it is you know that ability to control
the courthouse is an essential function
of that judge who's presiding in that
hearing
um
parties do have the right to introduce
evidence and testimony and that that's
just that is a a right that exists in
court I can't speak to why in a
particular case a judge may have limited
or or prohibited some element of
testimony I just you know that is a very
case-specific time-specific issue and I
I simply can't address it but the fact
is parties at a hearing have the right
to introduce evidence and testimony but
it is controlled generally as as
as Miss gay spoke to you know we do have
a rule that says essentially while
they're not while the Rules of Evidence
don't apply strictly they do apply for
purposes of ensuring the reliable and
and predictable nature of a proceeding
um so this bill would essentially remove
the ability of a judge to control that
courtroom control the flow of
information and also ensure that all
cases that are that are need to be heard
get heard
and we have a significant level of
concern about the impact that this bill
would have on court proceedings and the
rights of parties to be actually heard
before the judge with that I'll conclude
my comments but would be happy to answer
your questions thank you questions
representative Moulton
thank you Mr Vice chairman um I'm just
wondering if in the event that the
language changes were implemented that
we were discussing earlier before in
this hearing
would that have a positive or negative
or neutral effect on so it would depend
on the words
um and I apologize you know I can only
speak to this bill it
yeah
it probably won't be worse
um uh but I don't I don't sort of know
if the goal is to allow parties to
introduce evidence without restriction
it's always going to create the same
problem
the questions
representative both
thank you Vice chair
my question
um I'm just wondering you had mentioned
that the disparate disparity of time and
wealth makes it unfair doesn't that
happen every anyway given that some some
parties can afford an attorney and some
can't so wouldn't
um I'm not really understanding how that
applies here since it's already unfair
so um thank you for the question I I
would you know there is always a not
always but there can be disparity
between parties and and uh and what
they're they have an ability to bring
some of that is ultimately managed by
the judge to ensure that parties who
um
to ensure that parties can be heard and
and do get heard
um so it is sort of when you get into
the courtroom
um the opportunity is there for for both
parties and it is the judge's sort of
ability to control that testimony and
the information that provides the The
More Level Playing Field so I won't
disagree that that certainly there is a
potential disparity between wealth time
availability but once you're in that
courtroom
um both parties should have the
opportunity and do have the opportunity
to present evidence and again I can't
speak to a specific case where evidence
was limited as to why
um but that is how you know in terms of
the judge what the judge can do is to
ensure that the parties do have the
opportunity to present and talk to the
judge
mm-hmm
representative long I
think of Mr chairman uh
so I understand the hearing of the uh
specific issue so I'm going for this
hearing is on a financial matters
um I have evidence that will I believe
will get me
um more time with my child so I want to
submit that evidence
if this bill is passed even with the
language change
I can submit that evidence however the
court the judge could say I'm not going
to admit it because we're not here on uh
time spent with the child it it's it's
not the issue could it could a judge do
that
that's what the judge says now you know
if somebody were to bring forward so as
you thank you for the question so
somebody were to bring forward you know
during a a hearing on distribution of of
money or or the you know particular
asset the sale of a house and they tried
to bring up you know parenting time
um they would not be allowed to do it in
that in that proceeding and they would
be asked to stop doing that in the
proceeding similar to what you do in in
the Committee hearing and say
essentially that's a different issue
we'll deal with that later or we've
already dealt with that if you want to
amend your parenting schedule file a
motion on it
um you know there's a process for for
having that come before the judge if you
were to say
it may be completely irrelevant
introduce it anyway and then the judge
can decide later on whether or not it is
going to ultimately be admissible as
evidence one you've consumed that
incredibly valuable time in a courtroom
um for whatever length it may take it
may be I want to try my entire case when
the hearing is about the sale of a house
um and then secondly if I'm the other
party
I don't know you know I may not know I
gotta respond to everything that just
just was heard so I may have prolonged
what I'm testifying to
um or presenting because now the judges
heard all these other things that are
completely irrelevant and and it would
be
hard-pressed for a party if the other
side just spent an hour talking about
parenting time when the issue is the
sale of a house not to spend a great
deal of time talking about parenting
time and all you do is now start talking
about parenting time when the reality is
we're just trying to get the sale of the
house done a quick follow-up thank you
on line six the coach you'll note in the
record of the preceding any evidence not
admitted so the court has to look at the
evidence
I
that does that mean not write it write a
note uh there was evidence
presented on X I didn't admit it or does
that look like I need to have I need to
note the actual evidence
um on so I I did not take the evidence
on parenting time however
the evidence was
it I'm kind of confused on on a note to
me as a note uh however the evidence not
admitted do I is it the actual evidence
that I have to at least that's not so
thank you for the question I don't know
what what specifically the bill would
intend by the word no to my mind could
be verbal
um it could be written afterward
um
not specific in the bill as to what that
meant so it would be sort of subject to
interpretation subsequently
um but again
whether or not the judges is admitting
it I think as the other side I would be
hard-pressed not to spend an awful lot
of time talking about the a bunch of
irrelevant stuff that just got
talked about by the other side sure I
think just one human nature and two
um sort of the judges now heard it it's
now sort of in the judge's head I now
want to make sure the judge understands
the other perspective so it would just
significantly disrupt hearings okay
thank you representative ball
thank you chairman
um just another follow-up I'm sorry
thank you for taking my question so if
they included the word where it says on
line four shall have the right to
present evidence if they included the
word relevant evidence would that at
least cut it down and allow the judge to
to make determinations of uni it's this
is not relevant to the case so like you
were saying if you're talking about the
sale of the house that doesn't have to
do with child time so in that case it
would be like that's not going to that's
not going to be admissible or I'm not
going to take that because it's it's not
relevant to what we're discussing
um
so relevance may not so thank you for
the question
generally that's an improvement it's
what happens already so I'm not sure why
it needs to be in statute it doesn't
change anything but relevance may not be
the only issue
um in terms of of its presentation
um
so it it would
it would it would narrow this bill it
thank you attorney head appreciate your
testimony thank you we're coming up on a
deadline so I'd ask any remaining
testimony to be uh succinct and to the
point chair calls representative J.D
Bernardi who wishes to testify on this
bill
representative JD Bernardi from
Rockingham 36.
um I did not plan to testify today but
after hearing uh attorney head speak I
just I had to
um the fundamental premise of this law
is is that the Rules of Evidence shall
apply and the court shall not have the
ability to say we're not going to allow
them to apply that's the fundamental
principle and if you look at the if you
look at the uh the the amendment it
basically says if evidence is presented
that's not relevant not not appropriate
or or specific evidence to the uh is not
um
is is not is not relevant then the
reason just needs to be identified it's
that simple for the judge to say okay
you presented a bunch of evidence that's
not relevant to the to the point that
we're discussing today there's nothing
wrong with that but we're asking for
Rules of Evidence to be the standard by
which court proceedings are held and
there's no reason why the Family
Division should be the only division of
our court system that says rules don't
apply
thank you any questions for
representative Bernardi representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for being here and testifying is there
an amendment I don't have an amendment
there is not an amendment yet okay
making sure
if there's an amendment I don't have it
it did not get to me I don't have any
money I went to the prime sponsor is it
looks like going to be crafting an
amendment which if it gets here before
noon we will consider when we exec the
Bill thank you for the question though
anything else
no okay good thank you representative I
have a pink card for Bill 479 that if
that is if Katrina Heinrich from Exeter
wishes to speak to this bill here I'll
make the change on the card welcome
I realize with inflation it might have
become Bill 479 but you never know so
I'm Katrina and I'm from Exeter New
Hampshire thank you for taking this and
changing my number
um I wanted to speak to this just real
quickly because
as eloquently as as attorney head puts
how the court is supposed to work and
the options that the judges have and to
maintain control of the Court it is
important and I don't think anybody can
dispute that
however what can be disputed is attorney
head continues to come back to we need
to get 20 people in a day we need to do
this which I've testified to in another
bill
this is exactly what I'm talking about
we never resolve the issue he talks
about one issue at a time
a decade-long case
does not have one issue at a time unless
they're created
and when there's no Witnesses allowed
and I pack the I pack the courtroom
three different times
not one witness was allowed to stay in
the room let alone testify
I brought evidence
of job offers
not admitted
I brought evidence of the deterioration
of my children from the schools not
admitted
the only thing that mattered was what
the judge was doing to me and that was I
was not allowed evidence ever
and that's a problem
that's a big problem because
like you I assume you would want your
evidence to be heard
my evidence was not heard I had children
that were extremely harmed because of
this 10 years come back into court keep
coming back into court that's more
than an Evidence issue
that's as attorney head said you get 20
more in we gotta get 20 more in well if
you'd have resolved it we wouldn't be
here
so
when it comes to that that's all I have
to say about it evidence is crucial it
is not being heard in all cases perhaps
there are some that they do
but for the most part in my experience
over a decade no
and that's all I have
thank you for your testimony with that
I'm closing the hearing on the house
bill 475 we will execut later today we
have to exec all the bills before us
today and we will exec this one with
without any amendments that come to me
with that I open the exact session on
House Bill 10 and again I'm taking these
out of the printed order depending on
people that we may need this is not a
hearing no pink cards but we may ask
different Prime sponsors for
clarifications or if they're bringing in
amendments specifically what that
Amendment does so with that the chair
recognizes representative Paul Terry one
of the authors
of the original House Bill 10 who has a
new Amendment
and I'm passing it around you saw the
previous Amendment which was supposed to
be the bill it didn't happen that way
this is a an amendment now to what you
have seen before procurement and
representative would you Mr chairman
who's speaking uh Larry uh
representative hi hi uh are we going to
caucus before we exact
that depends okay at my discretion okay
or the call of the vice chair if you
wish to we'll get our heads together
no I think we've done it
uh representative gagne and Stephen
Pearson the Republicans have caucused on
the bills for today and we're glad
you're here to fill seeds
uh representative Terry please tell us
the difference of this amendment thank
you Mr chair I'm in the uncharacteristic
of his position position of uh being
needed in two places at the same time uh
this um bestowal of importance upon me
is quite astonishing I'll try to get
through this as quickly as I possibly
can I'm here to speak to the changes
that have been made in HP 10 FN
um
subsequent to the the hearing
last week I believe it was yes
uh representative
D Simone from the committee has joined
if everyone has a copy of the amendment
let me speak to uh or inform you of the
three changes
well actually two changes and one we're
not going to do anything uh items here
so if you if you turn if you turn to
page four
and you
the preceding Roman numeral three on
line 25 reads this section does not
colon a
line 26.
so proceeding authorize a parent of a
minor child in this state to engage in
conduct that is unlawful or to abuse or
neglect his or her minor child in
violation of General law semicolon what
has been removed
are the words pursuant to RSA 186 colon
11.
Roman numeral 9-c and the reason for
that
as pointed out by
attorney head who just testified
um a few moments ago and thank you to
attorney head
RSA
18611 Roman numeral 9-c is actually it's
a mistake being here the reason is that
none of the entities or persons that are
cited
in item a and uh B I'm sorry uh if I'm
sorry we need to go to B prohibit a
court of competent jurisdiction law
enforcement officer or employees of a
government agency that is responsible
for child welfare from acting in his or
her official capacity so you see named
parties here Court of competent
jurisdiction law enforcement officer or
employees of a government agency
RSA 18611 Roman numeral 9-c references
to the part of the Department of
Education
the department of education does not
have any jurisdiction over any of these
parties so that reference pursuant to
has been struck
the second change
appears
in response to the concern or question
and concern raised by representative
long
whereby in lines 26 and following but
specifically I'm sorry lines 11 and
following in the previous version and in
this version
uh
once again line 11 the First new
sentence
and the only new sentence appearing on
line 11 any contractor or third party
employed by the school that violates any
section this bill shall be fined twenty
five hundred dollars and be restricted
from any further access to all schools
the replacement that we've made in the
amendment is in in this version is in
the state replacing in the district and
that's in response to the concern and
the question raised by representative
long with respect to the question of a
possible unfair Labor practice
so in line 13
you see the words in the state and then
you also see that repeated online in
line embedded within line 14 plus
permanent restriction from all schools
in the state replacing the words in the
the Third
okay would you take questions now or do
you wish to finish with respect to this
change to this change is it to this
so just to clarify so this is almost a
more severe punishment so before it was
just the school district
and now it's the entire State you've
expanded the
yes the state would is a larger
jurisdiction than the district
um it's for a period of one year for the
first offense and you changed it why
because representative long had raised a
question about a possible unfair Labor
practice challenge with respect to not
being able to uh apply for employment in
we prohibited employment in the district
where the offense occurred
but we did not address the question of
applying for employment in any other
school district in the state of New
Hampshire so the response to
representative Long's concern we changed
in the district to in the state and in
response to representative Grossman's
question yes it's the state now in view
not just the District representative
long
thank you Mr chairman so yeah yeah it
would be labor law people have a right
to
work anywheres and original Amendment
says that you would be allowed to work
in other districts in the state so this
takes you out of the state however
uh on on this on a new one it says that
um
to all schools in the state so that's a
private school a boarding school
because the Declaration of purpose says
I'm sorry when you referenced this uh
so evaluation Declaration of purpose on
the first page uh actually it's in line
seven well being with the minor child in
the custody of the school district so
that at the beginning it specifies
school district
and then
and then at the end well not at the end
but the the punitive damage is all
schools within the state
so I'm thinking a Catholic school I
can't teach at uh boarding school uh any
any school that's not a state that's
I could teach at any school that's not a
district in the school district
so I'm not a lawyer but if in fact the
governing
uh definition is provided in
section one at the beginning of the bill
then
it may very well be interpreted that
all schools in the state would apply to
only those schools that are in view
within section one
might not be actually the reverse that
the Declaration of purpose is saying hi
guys this is what we want to do and what
follows that is law
even though it's all enshrined in the
lsrs the Declaration of purpose is not
determinative over any item in the body
of it itself so that your page six would
really be more Cooperative yes thank you
for that uh observation and
clarification I'm still clearing the
snow from my mind so yeah I appreciate
that yes thank you any other questions
on what the representative has said on
that
point
okay go to your third point please okay
representative Bickford third and lastly
representative Beckford raised the
question at the at the at the first
hearing at the hearing about
um school resource officers
whether they uh should be included or
not what did we think
we had not considered school resource
officers any of us in the drafting of
the bill however subsequently we've
begun to do some research into
the uh the role uh the role of the
school resource officer or roles of the
school resource of school resource
officers and also their relationships to
the school
district into the uh the police
department or departments which employ
them and the problem here
is that we cannot hold
the school resource officer to the same
standard as we hold School District
employees because this this student
resource officer is not an employee of
the school district he or she is there
on contract
um with the local police law enforcement
jurisdiction his or her primary
relationship is therefore to the law
enforcement agency and not to the school
board
and so uh and and furthermore we're not
real clear about
um the roles and relationships of school
resource officers in all the many many
many many many many districts in uh in
New Hampshire so if there were to be any
kind of concern about including school
resource officers
Under the Umbrella of this bill a lot
more work needs to be done and and
school resource officers here are not
essential to this particular
bill as to whether it should be voted up
or down representative long think of Mr
chairman
um so on the first page on line 23
actually it's line 25 it includes other
governmental entities in other
institutions so
like nurses are contracted
uh well I know in Manchester uh you know
actually we stopped Contracting and they
belonged to the school district now uh
but there were some districts that
contract with nurses
um and sros I would believe would be
oh that's quite possible and that makes
sense
and so um I thank you for being helpful
on that point
uh
clearly was something that we overlooked
as we were as really zeroing in on the
the question of the relationship of the
student resource officer and uh clearly
um apparently missed the reference here
to governmental entity
this was a multi-party effort and I I
was I'm not trying to excuse myself but
I wasn't particularly responsible for
that section but I believe that's a good
uh see on your part and I want I want to
thank you for that
would you prepared to run down to OLS
and get this clarified so what we vote
on will take into account what we just
heard
they'll just have to change one line
the one line being
well uh somewhere where in you put in a
clause not counting school resource to
make it clear no no it's not in here no
we we did not include School resources
we didn't have to name them yeah but
line 25 indicates that it could be
school resources if you're talking about
any other governmental Essence
Department would they not be covered
already there's no need to actually
reference them yeah I I mean even if you
were to add sros then I would have other
issues because I would not my son I
writing out I can't think of another
word I'd come from the get old so I
can't think of another word for writing
out I wouldn't I wouldn't want I
wouldn't want my son
my child to be ratting out uh
somebody so I would as a parent I would
say to the SRO
don't go after my don't go after my kid
to get information on this kid I don't
want my son telling any information on
this child so I think that
I think that creates a more it makes it
yeah you're not saying specifically
ruling out sros as a line item would
make any difference for you on the bill
so so there's no point okay any other
questions for uh representative Terry on
just the three changes so since nothing
happened with sros it's not a change so
it's the elimination of pursuant to
on page four I believe and then changing
on Page Six
in The District in the state
yes
any further questions
regarding the amendment from one of the
Prime sponsors of it
because then we will simply discuss
amongst ourselves thank you so much
representative and you're off to a an
exec session too
late to a caucus in time for exec thank
you
now we can speak to each other and
please be brief because we have a lot of
bills and we're going to be evicted
after uh 12 o'clock or so well I'd like
I'll second that I actually have
um that already in my script
I'm sorry
no
just yeah the chair is making a motion
OTP
and DeSimone is seconded that
now we can discuss and that would be I
make the motion to OTP House Bill 10
with amendment
917h that is the formal official motion
it includes this latest Amendment we
just got
okay anybody want to speak sure somebody
representative
um betrayal
okay thank you Mr chairman
so we heard testimony uh last time
regarding this bill and to quote
um one of the sponsors
I believe he said everything else is
already explicitly stated in the RSA
everything else other than the
provisions w x and y
in other words
parental rights already exist
the entire Bill okay is such that every
single right enumerated already exists
for example the right to opt out of sex
education
parents can already opt out of
absolutely anything they don't want
their children to participate in and I
can go line by line by line and argue
the point that every single right
enumerated already exists it makes this
whole legislation really pointless
except for W X and Y and W X and Y says
that
upon inquiry if a parent asks a teacher
a specific question
the teacher must answer
well that is not a right as a matter of
fact I was actually in a hearing in
another committee where this whole
discussion about natural inalienable
rights was discussed
and I was surprised to hear that one of
the conservative members said
no one has a right to force you to do
something against your will
so I as a teacher if a parent comes to
me and says I want to know if my child
has expressed to you concerns about
gender identity
I don't have to answer that
and that is not really a matter of
keeping secrets
ask me how is my kid doing is he turning
in his homework is he paying attention
in class and I will happily answer that
but if you ask me
has my child expressed concerns about
their gender identity my response as a
teacher would be I think you have to go
home and talk to your child about that
because kids and I taught for 40 years
they come to their teachers and they
talk about everything
and they just need an adult where they
can vent during their school day
and there is no way I am going to
violate their confidentiality because
once I do that they're never coming to
me to talk to me about absolutely
anything
and the reality is that there are kids
who when outed go home and are abused by
their parents
and this is not just me saying so the
child advocate testified and said that
and I'm quoting on a daily basis her
office has instances of children who are
abused by their parents once they find
out that they're having questions about
their gender identity
so
why w x and y are not inalienable rights
to call them rights and to put them in a
Bill of Rights when they are not rights
just take that completely out of the
equation they're not rights no one is
going to force me to say anything that I
feel is in inappropriate
all the other rights that are in there
they already exist
this bill is meaningless
thank you
representative D Simone
when we had a a similar Bill last term
what I'm about to talk about was not in
that bill and it did not protect the
children this particular Bill not only
protects the parents
and their rights but it also protects
the children and if you go to page four
line 25
Roman numeral three it says
this section does not and then it goes
on to specific a in B lowercase A and B
in paraphernal and then section
um sections four five and so on
it protects the children who are going
to go home and be
smacked or abused in any other manner
thrown out of the house whatever it also
opens up dialogue so that there is a
teacher parent and a child being able to
talk amongst themselves and the trained
Professionals in the school can see
If the child is in danger when they get
home
you know we're all born the way we're
born
and much of the testimony last week was
in
serious concern for the lgbtq
transgender kids and so forth
those kids are born the way they born
they believe what in their heart they
believe and
it's up to the legislature to protect
those kids it's up to the legislature to
protect the adults we don't know
specifically
if those kids who are claiming to be
transgender it's just a fad or it
actually is that they are
we can't make that determination but we
can protect those kids so that's why
um section three on page four was put
into the bill was to protect those kids
and make sure
that we're also protecting the parents
and that's why I believe that this bill
is relevant and it needs to be passed
I'd like to let everybody have a chance
to go around and then we can come back
uh representative Raymond
um thank you Mr chairman
um to be clear we wouldn't need to have
extra predictions for those kids if we
didn't have extra sections under w x and
y that specifically discriminate against
those children so it seems really
counter-intuitive to me to specifically
expand state law to add in
discrimination against lgbtq Youth and
then a few paragraphs later be like oh
but please don't abuse them we know very
clearly that telling parents not to
abuse their kids doesn't do anything to
protect kids from abuse they get abused
every day and we know
because many many experts medical
experts and psychological experts have
told us that lgbtq plus kids are at
greater risk of both abuse and neglect
and mental health issues including
suicide
because parents are more likely to
reject them or treat them badly once
they come out so if kids are saying it
is not safe for you to tell Mom and Dad
that I'm having an issue with my gender
identity it is completely irresponsible
and frankly I think immoral for the
state to step in and tell teachers too
bad
put your conscience to the side put
reporting to dcyf and the police to the
side until after you've informed the
parents and if you don't we're going to
impose criminal penalties on you that's
ridiculous
teachers are mandated reporters they're
required to tell dcyf and the police if
they have concerns let those experts do
their jobs don't put stuff into state
law that's based on a few legislators
personal beliefs thank you
representative representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman I have a few
points to bring up
um first thing is that I think all of
you know I try to research these
feels very thoroughly in Seal sides I
have heard from and I have spoken with
people from the lgbtq plus community
who are against this bill and I have
also spoken to people from this
community who are for this bill
I want to also talk about
my experience as a parent time has gone
by I will not reveal the um
the name of this person I think that
this person's anonymity will be safe
my daughter several years ago came home
from school and said Mom my friend
long time friend has changed their name
and they will now be a girl name instead
of a boy name and they are wearing a
dress today it was the first day and
they will be dressing like a girl
my daughter is very kind I raise my
children to be kind and so my response
to her was I hope you will continue to
be a good friend and be a support to
your friend and she was my point of
talking about my experience is that
um when a child
is asking the school Community to refer
to them by another name
or another gender pronoun they're outing
themselves in the school Community kids
go home and they share things with their
parents
there is a good chance that the majority
of the people in the community will know
that this child has outed themselves at
school but the parents will not have the
opportunity if they have a feeling that
their child might be they will not be
given the opportunity to have an honest
answer come from the school we heard in
testimony earlier in the day about a
separate bill
about the importance of a parent being
afforded the opportunity to provide
um
support to their children
because the incident of unsupported uh
transgender youth the incidence of
suicide is exponentially increased when
they're not supported by their parents
yet in the afternoon we heard that
parents shouldn't be given the
opportunity to support their children or
their children will commit suicide
um so I my last thing is that if a child
comes to an educator or another person
in the school and says
this is
my situation if my parent calls and asks
you they're going to abuse me isn't it
um their
their
responsibility as a mandated reporter to
report that statement thank you
representative Nelson representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman
um this hits deeply personal basically
because the 16 year old that was very
brave and came in and shared with you
guys happens to be my daughter we were
in that situation
I not only worked within my own family
my own children as to how to get them
out of our situation I've worked with
hundreds of women who have children who
go through this kind of situation
I think that it's honorable that
representative DeSimone says that you
know she doesn't want kids to get abused
doesn't want them to get hurt and she
thinks that that you know couple lines
will make the difference unfortunately
these parents already know that this
probably isn't okay and this is why they
have secrets however they don't
necessarily look at it as abuse they
look at it as control
I'm going to spank you I'm going to beat
you because you're out of control you're
not doing something within my control
if you heard Emma Greg say the other day
and she she did quote it we had some
statistics come in that we've never
gotten proof of we've had some oh
there's many cases none of us have
gotten any information that we asked for
however she said the National Children's
Alliance in 2020 out of the 618 000
children were victims of abuse
77 percent of them were by the parents
which leaves very little room for
everything else whether it be teachers
or whatever else in the abuse teachers
are not perfect however
I do know and I would be surprised that
anybody who's worked with abuse victims
doesn't know that a child never is able
to come out because of the brow beating
that they get mentally and say hey you
know what I'm abused what children do is
they do a test reveal it is something
that might be a little bit not like hey
I had peanut butter and jelly at home
but it's going to be something a little
bit closer my own children did this they
see if they can trust what's going to
happen what the response will be will
their parents find out if they don't
find out you'll get a reveal like I did
one year when a little boy finally told
me that his dad his new stepdad was
waking him up in the middle of the night
it took three questionable things of him
telling me things that were kind of like
weird like hey I lost all my toys before
he finally trusted me enough to tell me
that there are test questions we are
taking that protection away from these
children 77 percent of these that are
getting abused by their parents thank
you
thank you Mr chairman best interest of
the child
uh Moulton representative ball
thank you chairman when we talk about
the best interest of the child we really
should be thinking about the fact that
our teachers are employees at will they
are there to teach the curriculum they
are not trained to be counselors and
they should not be expected to be
counselors when a student goes to a
teacher and confides in them anything
that student should be referred to the
counselor in the school if the student
is saying that they
feel anxiety depression suicidal that is
the reason teachers refer to special
education for a social emotional
disability it means there is something
getting in the way of that child
to access the curriculum and if they're
talking to teachers about situations it
is not the teacher's responsibility to
take on that child
as their
someone they're going to counsel that is
beyond what is expected of a teacher in
a public school it is beyond what a
parent expects they expect their child
to see a counselor they expect their
child to get referred to special
education to deal with any kind of
Social and emotional issues including
anxiety depression and suicide
so I am very concerned that when we keep
talking about teachers addressing our
children that we are changing our
educational institutions into mental
health facilities and that is not what
they are there for
so let's think of the best interest of
the child and direct the child to the
people in the school system who can be
best trained to address their concerns
thank you thank you representative
representative Perez who had your hand
up
thank you Mr Sherman I'm very concerned
I'm very concerned if we pass this bill
let me tell you why
this will take the ability your
children's
to be able to cheer
the abuse they're getting at home
especially when it comes from a parent
you're not speaking
I already testified many times and
already shared my story
thou will take away
the riot child like myself
to be safe why did we keep saying that
we want to keep the kids safe this is
not the bill that is going to keep the
kid safe this is against the safe of the
child and this is against
oh that say for the all the teachers
because this is putting the teachers and
rests not just to penalize and paying
these twenty five hundred dollars
but this kind of language
is not making for the teachers to be
safe or anyone who worked in the school
system to be feel safe we already know
the attacks in the school system and
thank you representative representative
panic
thank you chairman Pearson for allowing
is the public schools a government
program
it's is this a government overreach to
separate children from parents
to hide what is being taught
when China fell to Communism in 1949 the
first thing the CCP did is take over the
schools
so when we have division between the
parents
in the children
in the schools being the wedge
this is when we lose our country
thank you
thank you representative
representative Levesque
as someone who is is very young compared
to many of you being in school was very
recent for me
I had a teacher who let me and a couple
other students go up to his classroom
during lunch because he understood that
the cafeteria can sometimes be a little
bit overwhelming for some of us and he
allowed us to come and eat upstairs he
gave us a hall pass
and I trusted him I trusted many of my
teachers who were there supervising me
giving me my education
and having that trust taken away with
this bill is very very scary thank you
thank you representative representative
Grossman
thank you Mr chairman
um
to echo on so much of what we've already
heard
and from the office of the child
advocate we heard that this bill would
harm children
um and I just want to reiterate this
harms our lgbtq youth this harms
educators
this is not good for New Hampshire and
for our students and so I will be voting
against
anybody who has not spoken in this round
yet like representative law
thank you Mr chairman um
I'm kind of at odds as why this is only
towards public teachers because I sent
my child to private school and I didn't
have parental rights in that private
school so I I don't know what we're
trying to fix here uh and and
representative girl Smith had it right I
mean I asked everybody to read that uh
uh the child the child Advocates uh
communication I mean it's it's just
clear in here uh a couple short years
ago we uh
we added to 169 C the child protection
act best interest of the child you know
we added more of the best interests of
the child uh we also
um
uh the governor and Council has has also
contracted uh with the one trusted adult
program this is kicking out right out
the window there will be no trusted
adults
uh and finally the the
um
uh the chilling effect on a relationship
between children and teachers guidance
counselors uh and and that
according to the office of child
advocate which I agree with this has
this has nothing in the best interest of
the child I hear it but it has nothing
in the bill with respect to the best
interest of the child thank you Miss Jim
thank you Vice chairman uh now round two
representative
Petrino
thank you Mr chairman a couple of points
um
as I mentioned before I've had students
come to me and discuss all kinds of
things
and again
you know you hold their
confidentiality
if it's something like
God forbid suicide or anything like that
teaches them not in a position to
counsel so you do
speak to guidance counselors and all of
those appropriate
personnel but you know I just think of a
young couple seniors a boy and girl who
were dating and they decided to break up
because they knew it was inevitable they
were going to be great breaking up at uh
graduation anyways moving on to
different colleges and they came to me
to confide and I said you know it's the
middle of the school year you know why
don't you just enjoy your senior year
and see what happens
they took my advice they thanked me
today they're married
my only regret is they didn't name their
firstborn child after me
to be quite honest
so teachers do more than just sit there
and play the role of psychiatrists it's
not their role but kids do talk to you
about all kinds of things and you want
to maintain that relationship and the
issue here is the relationship between
the parent and the child there are many
children who willingly speak to their
parents about issues regarding gender
identity they do so because they feel
comfortable they kind of get a sense
that Mom and Dad are okay with this and
so they reveal it
the children who don't
talk to Mom and Dad and kind of feel
things out at school are the ones who
really worry that Mom and Dad are going
to be abusive when is the right time for
me to come out is my dad going to freak
out but I still gotta
express myself somehow maybe what my
friends or some teachers or whatever
so the parent-child relationship is very
important and many children do come out
willingly and others are rightly so a
little fearful okay and we need to take
that into consideration
and lastly
again you take a look at why W Y X and Y
I don't want to be over dramatic here
but it almost reminds me of gestapo
tactics
tell me what I want to know
otherwise
your life is in Jeopardy I can again not
wanting to be very dramatic here but you
put a gun to someone's head and say tell
me what I want to know in this instance
tell me what I want to know or you are
subject to civil and criminal liability
and you're going to lose your job so
tell me what I want to know and again
those are not inalienable rights to put
them in a Bill of Rights and call them
rights when they're not rights and this
is not just me look it up in any
conservative uh Forum that discusses the
concept of natural inalienable rights
conservatives will tell you these are
not rights and all the other rights that
thank you representative and the chair
apologizes that in the flurry of paper
that came in last week the testimony
from the last individual
um
was not handed out so I'm sending around
a batch of these to to you
um
this was from the person who starts off
saying I was a transgender woman for
over 20 years and ends with to hide
irreversible and damaging mental or
medical therapy or procedures about a
child to his her parents is above and
beyond criminal it must be stopped
that you may remember some of you had to
leave but that was the last
um piece of testimony anyone else in
round two and it's got to be brave
because you know the clock is sticking
representative Raymond
thank you Mr chairman and I will be as
concise as humanly possible
um we've talked a lot about
a lot of the spill um but I just wanted
to bring everyone's attention to
um one small thing that is a not so
small and is a pet peeve of mine
um and that is when language isn't tight
uh when it is vague or misleading and in
this particular Bell on page one line
seven and page one line 21.
um we have some legal terms being used
inappropriately it says while the minor
child is in the custody of the school
district we know that kids are not in
the custody of schools they're in the
custody of their parents and parents
have to sign permission slips for
schools to do anything we know that
school districts do not act in loco
parentis in loco parentis is a very
specific legal term I can't if I'm
working at a school make a decision
about medication I can't make a decision
about who a child gets dismissed to I
can't make any kinds of decisions about
what parents have the right to make the
decisions for if I want my child to be
in the custody of someone else or
someone else to act in local parentis I
actually have to either go to court or
get a notarized statement giving that
person the rights that's why parents
have to be involved in things like IEP
meetings and other other meetings that
the school has so it's really
um irritating to me to start off a bill
utilizing terms that simply aren't
appropriate or accurate
thank you representative representative
ball round two
respect I believe that you've misdated
the schools do act in love espressos
that's why we have nurses who can give
out medications and take care of
children and I have head school
districts say that yes they are too
working in Locust in Lotus breakfast
that being said as a teacher in all my
years in school I know that all the
teachers refer to the children as these
are my students my students but the fact
of the matter is they are not my
students they do not belong to me they
belong to their parents and their
parents are the ones who make the
decisions for them
round two briefly representative Greg
thank you Mr chairman so on the medicine
thing even for Tylenol I've had three
kids just recently we had to have
permission slips from the parents for
the even Tylenol or any kind of
medication or they where I had to go to
school to give it so um that's one
problem the other thing is I've had
teachers
um by the way when we had to tell what
my kids had been through that broke down
crying not because they were just their
teachers because when I couldn't protect
my kids and they were at school I knew
their emotional well-being was there and
they were very well attached to our kids
and and might they couldn't
even fathom how these three kids who are
functioning so well were in these
classes but I I've had them come to um
different events for the kids because of
this connection that they had and
because my kids could trust them and
talk to them about things they weren't
quite even ready to trust me with just
yet
okay my turn
in terms of parental rights in private
schools
the parents have the rights that you
contract with that school for
early on in my life I was on the staff
of Saint Timothy's Church in Baltimore
Maryland we had a parochial school
there was a contract if your kid goes to
Saint Tims you have read the above
you must do the following you may not do
the following we'll talk about the rest
Etc
once you signed it
that's the limit or the extent of the
rights you have
we had Parents read through it and say I
don't want to sign it
okay Saint Williams around the corner
has a very nice school maybe they're
taking new students
secondly
I was highly annoyed by the phrase it
takes a village for a long time until I
came to agree with it
the question here is in the village
who's the mayor
thirdly
we talk about particular gender issues
because that's the hot button issue
right now it may be something else and
we'll need to broaden this should this
pass
I want to know
if my child has been flirting
with white supremacy
I get a little bit of hints at home
something that should have been locked
away that I don't have a key to but got
left out I'm wondering what's he doing
at school I have two ways I can ask
there's probably a blabbermouth kid in
the neighborhood that I've built up a
good relationship with and I might want
to ask that kid
I much would rather ask his kids my
child's teacher
and have an honest answer
so it doesn't just cut to the political
or ideological left it could cut in many
places to the political ideological
right as well
now in terms of abusive parents
some parents have abused their kids
before issues of gender come up
I rather wonder if the relationship with
the kid and the parents and we've
already said
there are some pretty rough
relationships I have a feeling it's
probably gotten to the reportable stage
already in some cases
also if or maybe we should say when a
parent learns about
wxy
from the blabbermouth kid
from the kid who said something to his
or her parents
and a very sincere whether misguided or
not is arguable but a sincere parent
says to the
transgender child
do you know what my daughter said is
that true
or worse in the mouth of a mean parent
is just waiting to rub that family down
the road's nose in it aha I know what I
know and the parents didn't learn it
from the teacher the parents didn't
learn it from the child the parent
learned it in the neighborhood on the
straight
I think the parents might be more Angry
not less because they were embarrassed
when they were told
also might the parents now wonder
can we trust the teachers
are they the mayor in the village in
their mind
I just want to point out numbers of
people surprising numbers of people took
advantage of educational accounts way
more than what we thought we all know
that
if teachers don't tell
when asked and notice that it's not a
mandate mandatory reportable thing
it is if asked tell truth
if parents find out this is happening
I wonder how many more people will want
to pull their kids out of the public
schools
a couple more points
I forget the movie title but there was
one maybe you saw it whether it was a
testing which predicts
who will commit a crime
person hasn't committed a crime yet
but that person tested as likely to
and the government came in on it
so
the parents are possibly statistically
going to beat the child
you've already convicted them of a crime
and then finally
there were 21 school districts that have
a transgender
non-conforming policy I kept it in my
phone so I can quote it exactly it reads
like this 21 New Hampshire school
districts that have transgender gender
non-conforming policies 21 school
districts that openly State you can get
it
that District Personnel can or should
keep a student's transgender status
hidden from the parents 21 school
districts already say that so
that's my weighing in
um
representative Perez Mr chairman
um I just want to add that something
that bothers me is you mentioned and did
a lot of parents now they send the kids
to private school because they don't
feel
heard in the school systems and you know
a lot of these kids you know a lot of
these parents they're taking advantage
that bothers me because when
I asked to the report for the report how
many children burn underrepresented
communities they've really taken
advantage of that really getting the
money to go in private school
I asked for the report and they they
would told me that that report was going
to send to me never got sent to me so it
bothers me to hear the more parents I
want to know where parents this is the
parents already have kids in private
schools and now they're taking advantage
and taking my money from the public
schools and taking away the money for
programs they've been helping
underrepresented communities and we're
taking away the money and then we feel
so proud the parents now more parents
are going to be able to to take the kids
away from the public school but when we
asked for the report how many children
how many new children for
underrepresented communities taking
advantage of this program no one has
that the report no matter Perez I'm
going to rule this non-germaine it's an
important subject but it is not this
bill why are you mentioning so that's
why I mentioned it as well because if we
want to be honest we have to be honest
and you are now uh finished
representative disamoni thank you Mr
chair we've heard a lot about people's
opinions on WX and Y
we're assuming
um in some of those opinions that
these uh three sections are not
important because the child could be
harmed
this gives the parents an opportunity to
help that child earlier
sooner rather than later
if my child is choosing to be called a
different name
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
a bad thing but I want to counsel my
child and say hey
you don't like your name
um okay I personally always hated my
name
and I was always called by a nickname
that I chose in school
so it could be something very innocent
as yeah I I don't like the name you gave
me
kids don't have a choice in the name
they're given
The Second One X
if a child is being identified by any uh
gender identity pronouns
most parents are good loving caring
nurturing parents
and if their child
is very confused which most kids when
they hit the puberty stage are
but these kids are now
defining themselves as a different
gender
I believe that it is the responsibility
to help that child
be able to sit with the parent and let
that parent help that child with whether
it be outside of the school
which in most places would most
instances would be help that child get
involved in counseling to help that
child through that difficult time and
help that child to understand
that the parents loved them enough to
say okay
if this is what you do and let's get
counseling and help us both understand
what it is that you're going through a
heterosexual parent is not going to
understand what a transgender kid is
going through and it's their
responsibility to help that child
and if we don't give them the
opportunity soon enough it will harm the
child
extracurricular activities and wrap it
up okay thank you I will
extracurricular activities and clubs If
the child gets harmed and the parent
hasn't signed a permission slip the
parents Insurance isn't going to cover
any injuries that take place during
those extracurricular activities
sorry but that's the way it is and thank
you
thank you and I realize we could go on
all day
no
because we're going to repeat ourselves
again
and I would like to move on
because we have several more bills to
deal with
so I would like to call the question
everybody in the room
like to call the question on House Bill
10 is amended by
Amendment
2023-0917h moved by the chair as ought
to pass is amended and seconded by
representative D Simone the motion is
ought to pass as amended with the clerk
procedure a procedural question we're
voting on the amendment first we are
voting on the amendment first this is
why you get the big bucks Mr Vice
chairman
this is on the amendment thank you
and the chair will move the amendment
and representative D Simone will move
the second the amendment yes I will all
right now we can do it thank you so much
for that
it's no brain you know
it's Noble
are you turn around perfect thank you I
appreciate that I like this guy
would the clerk please call the roll
on the amendment chairman Pearson yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone
yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic
yes
representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman no
representative Levesque no
representative Petrina will be voting no
representative Perez
representative Greg no representative
Moulton no representative Raymond no 828
to no one's surprise the chair will now
entertain a second motion
I make a motion to itl the amendment
the amendment yes
do we need to do that no we don't we
need to now vote now we need to vote on
no
the amendment passed to amend the bill
so
we go to the original so
did the question if we could
yeah let's let's hold on for a minute
parliamentarily
go ahead yeah I I thought we approved
the uh
Amendment uh
0720h we did not we were not an exact
session on that what we did didn't we
didn't we I thought we accepted it into
the committee we Exempted it into the
committee so that we could read it
because that was the intent of the
sponsors to be the bill that was
informational okay so we didn't we did
house bill 10. is that correct everybody
yeah brain test yeah good okay
uh then the chair moves
ought to pass
on House Bill 10. I'll second that Andy
Simone second set
and now uh would the clerk please call
the roll the motion is ought to pass on
the original Bill house bill 10.
moved by representative Pearson M
Pearson seconded by representative D
Simone
Jim and Pearson yes
representative long no representative
DeSimone
yes
representative gagne yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball
representative panic
yes representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez
no representative Greg no
representative Moulton no
representative Raymond no 828
because this is the last day for this
um Vice chairman would you like to have
a very brief meeting of your people to
see who will write the the other report
the
itl report
so
do we have to do
we just did OTP what did we just do that
okay
that's eight eight that eight eight was
on OTP we now have to do itl on the
original bill
we did it on the amendment so I'll move
I'll move the I tell uh okay you know
and I'll second okay now it's itl
and when the clerk is ready
the motion now is itl on the original
House Bill Tam
so be careful folks if you
want the bill to go down in flames
you'll say yes if you want the build to
that was mostly for me
itl Jim and Pearson no
representative long yes
representative DeSimone no
representative gagne
no representative Nelson no
representative McMahon no
representative ball no
representative panic
now representative Stephen Pearson no
representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
of course yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
eight eight now I think we've got it all
done the right way we're supposed to do
it
I'm doing the blurb for OTP and the
clerk is doing the blurb for itl and
he's already got his written and I'm
going to stay after school to get mine
done parliamentary and query
can can this be sent to the floor as no
recommendation
that's the way we're going to do it
correct I believe so thank you sir
there's nothing one everything tied okay
this ends the um we just did the exact
session on House Bill 10.
uh and now
um let me look out there
the next thing that is up is going to be
I opened the exec session on HR house
resolution 14 there is an amendment that
I believe took into account
numbers of things that we said in the
hearing so the chair recognizes
representative Bernardi the author of
the amendment in the original Bill not
for another hearing but simply to
explain what the
um amendment number
thank you Mr chair JD Bernardi
Rockingham 36.
so uh what this bill did was uh take
into consideration uh the comments from
representative Lynn and attorney head in
uh
making improvements to the legislation
um
the primary paragraph there indicates uh
well first that the the initial bill had
a choice for this committee to either as
a committee of the whole be the be the
uh committee to address this issue or an
appointed committee
um the discussion had been that an
appointed committee was was more
appropriate
um so 11 state legislators and five
members of the public
um
and the second point is the most
important concern was to get the issues
that are continually in front of this
committee heard to gather evidence from
the the members of the public that have
or want the better word victims of the
system to get their testimony
and then that be followed up by the
committee's ability to ask
uh the the response on the various
issues and problem areas from the
guardian Idol items from uh children and
family law from the Bureau of Child
Support Services and from the Judiciary
and specifically with respect to
representative Lynn's comment
um that the testimony from the Judiciary
shall not cause the judge to violate the
rules of conduct or otherwise reveal
analysis of specific cases so
their analysis cannot be questioned but
the facts can be laid on the table and
the the
um the facts and the circumstances of
the case cannot be
declared inappropriate for review
thirdly and again I thank representative
Lynn uh for for this uh recommendation
that the committee can seek guidance
from from other organizations that may
have expertise in this area that being
the the bar association uh New Hampshire
legal assistance and the
a couple of uh Family Court oriented
organizations the national Center for
state courts or the National Council of
so those are organizations that that can
offer guidance on how
issues that this committee has dealt
with have been have been addressed in
other states or other areas and may be
very relevant to uh committees
investigation
the uh the remainder of the bill is
largely the tail end of what had been
there before is that there would be at
least three public hearings
um that would take place so probably
would be more because the the date of
coming up with the final report has been
extended to uh the end of December of
2024 not 2023 as the original bill as
stated to allow the committee to do a
thorough investigation and and ask all
the questions it needs to make a
positive recommendation on several of
the areas that you've been dealing with
um and have the time and the resources
to conduct that investigation and make
any questions on the amendment
specifically not to rehear the bill but
to ask any clarifying questions
representative Raymond thank you briefly
um I know that this was
um already gone has already gone through
of OLS
um but there's a lot of grammar
capitalization
Etc does that get fixed between now and
when it goes to the floor
like do I have to point out any of that
no no okay that was it thank you good
thank you
um
just to say to everybody in
representative Bernardi who's part of
everybody
um I've got a trail of how this bill
looked from the start and wow it's
getting so much better there were
breaches of house rules in the original
draft there were I thought
um the language could be rounded a
little bit softened and it has been
um I think what has come here
um will be a good parallel track and let
me explain
um I think you know that I've met with
the current Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court the retired chief justice which is
representative chairman Lynn
um
rep Judge David King who's the
administrative justice of um Circuit
Court which includes Family Court our
own uh rep attorney had to say we need
some continuing education for us for the
public a lot of people are angry because
they think something wrong is being done
sometimes it isn't wrong right they just
don't know why it's being done
um most of the law shows I see on TV are
criminal law it's different from circuit
court and Night Court isn't a good
example
um so as a result there needs to be that
ongoing educational process for us for
the wider population we're getting it
going we have that continuing education
meeting the last Tuesday afternoon of
the month y'all invited as many gay
would say
um
but having a couple of bills like this
runs a parallel track especially for
legislators so
um that really wasn't a question that
was kind of an executive statement but
while you're up I thought appreciate it
I'd say that
thank you any other any questions for uh
representative Bernardi if not we're in
the exact session so anybody wish to
I I think it's a lot better uh it's an
issue that needs to be looked at I agree
with that
I mean at the five knowledgeable members
of the public
uh the fact that they don't have a
voting a vote
I don't know who we're gonna
I don't know what five knowledgeable
members are going to want to sit on a
committee knowing they just have input
and no no vote
um but I I mean I could oversee that
hopefully we can get the five
um
there are new rules of the road for
committees as you may know
um
uh
and I think this is trying to take that
into account okay but anyone else anyone
else
um wow
uh somebody like to make a good motion
on this do you like to make a good
motion on this so I'll move on Amendment
2023-0894a so into house resolution 14
ought to pass on the amendment
we have somebody from the other side of
the playground who wants to uh
would she she's not in the playground at
all along I've been saying the other
side of the playground I didn't know
that okay
seeing none when ready the assistant
clerk can call the roll on
House Bill house resolution 14 Amendment
0894h move by representative long
seconded by representative ball with the
assistant clerk Now call the roll please
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes
representative D Simone yes
representative
gagne yes gagne
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes
representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrina yes
representative Perez
yes
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
and that's 16 yes zero Nas the chair
will now entertain a motion
we passed the amendment into the bill
now we have to vote on the bill as
amended right right
okay I'll I'll while you're up I'm not a
writer but so if somebody could help me
write the committee report I'll move to
uh the past as amended okie dokie and
somebody second from the other
playground on the schoolyard
representative ball he went to a tough
School
foreign
I've ghost written before but there's a
fee involved
the motion before us
no I get the fee
the motion before us is how spell house
2023-0894h the motion is ought to pass
as amended
the assistant clerk may call the
Whirlwind ready chairman Pearson
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative gagne yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
panic
yes
representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes
16 years zero Nays any objection to
consent
we got three fish
yeah my that's what's going through my
mind too is that I don't think house
resolutions can go on consent
so we all have an objection to consent
it does we do it goes on regular
calendar where more people are going to
read Vice chairman Long's report than
otherwise
I think that alone is good reason Mr
chairman
thank you
thank you you've been like a son to me
all right moving right a long oh that
ends the um exact session on house
resolution 14. thank you so much
now I open the exact session on House
Bill
438 the relative to the rights of
representation in Family Court
and
having consulted with legal friends
Jack McCoy the one
um
counselor head for two I'm passing
around Amendment 771 to this which I
believe will help the purpose of the
original bill
in such ways that
the judicial system will see this is a
good thing and uh I think everybody can
Mr chairman
that's me representative Perez yes
um
not a big deal but I would like to ask a
question in in
um when we have people sitting in um
to testify
even their representatives or members of
the public
how does the procedure for someone who
has a pink car that's supposed to give
it to the person at the end of the not
going around to to give that to the to
the chair I just have a question about
that that is correct thank you for that
observation the chair should have said
something and didn't so thank you so
much
it's easy to forget I caught myself
three quarters of the way in my old
committee going to the front because I
used to live there and and someone said
you gotta go so yeah I I have violated
that one so thank you all right
Amendment zero seven seven one the
amendment writer will speak to his
Amendment he actually did just a minute
ago and basically this encourages
um a support person to sit with
but remember there were concerns
uh that the support person may overreach
the role of being a support person and
kind to signal
things of course you can do that from
you know sitting behind the the rail as
well but sitting right up front there
interrupting of judicial procedure so we
we wanted to try to find that sweet spot
where
um the genuine objections of the judges
were heard but
some people's need for a companion was
also honored and this was the amendment
suggested to me so I slapped my name on
it and read it over it's 11 lines long
and uh
we can talk about it if you want to
representative long uh
think of Miss chairman we we didn't
this amendment uh and I don't know where
my caucus is because we worked on the
original bill
um so you want to take 10 minutes I
don't need 10 minutes you want to take
five minutes two minutes you want to
take two minutes yeah
wants to leave
no we'll go in the back room okay
okay all right thank you everybody from
this side of the playground goes into
careful
information
someone wants to make them
we are back all the kids are in their
respective seats in school from Recess
and representative long
um I don't know why I'm calling on you
I guess so I mean what were we doing
before
all right uh we are continuing
um House Bill
438 and the uh the chair will move
2023-0771h and moves that
ought to pass is there a second
on the amendment
is there a second on the amendment
this is uh yeah then we'll have a
discussion
you can do it either way is there a
second on the amendment
okay so I can just put Dittos
now we can discuss House Bill 438
Amendment and as I said this uh seems to
answer some of the concerns the judges
had but it takes out the whole language
about New Hampshire Coalition against
domestic violence employees it takes all
of that out but it leaves the fact that
at the discretion of the judge
representative Nelson
uh thank you Mr chairman
um with all due respect Mr chairman I um
understand that family domestic violence
situations can be very complex and
convoluted and I don't
um feel confident that this bill
um would prevent any kind of coercion
that could happen and even in a
non-verbal way where the judge would not
be able to see so for that reason I will
not be supporting this bill okay
it is your opinion that the judge would
not have
pretty much every time the discretion to
sniff that out and say you can't do that
thank you for asking me the question
um I don't think that the judge could be
um you know they have to pay attention
to a lot of aspects of the courtroom I
don't know if they would be able to pay
attention to a sigh or a foot tapping
um or a shrug
thank you anyone else wish to share
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson I too and am
not comfortable supporting this I am
concerned about the Optics that it
presents um to me it makes the defendant
look guilty
um without when he's just being accused
or she
anyone else representative
thank you Mr chair
um
I I see the the admirable intent
of the amendment
however
we're looking at the bill
under trying to understand that a person
who was abused
but we're not looking at the fact that a
person who is testifying may require
a a comfort person and they are the
abuser
so it doesn't say anything either in the
bill or this amendment concerning who
should have the Comfort person and if
it's the abuser the abuse is perpetuated
and if it's the abused who knows whether
the Comfort person is actually going to
comfort that person
so I'm very concerned about that aspect
not being clear in either the bill or
the amendment thank you thank you anyone
whichever one
whichever one works as long as you don't
call me late for dinner
Mr chairman uh I was a court security
officer when I retired from the post
office being a prior police officer
and I so I served in uh domestic uh
courts
as a the bailiff and I if I remember
right
there was
at the request of the abused of the
grief party
there was always someone with that
individual who could not take part in
testimony or anything like that would
just sit there as I don't know Comfort
person I guess just a reassurance so is
this necessary or I thought it was
already already in
Mr chair just clarify uh representative
gagne's statement it is already in
statute however it is only related to
Criminal
okay
um was that your experience
representative gagne
yeah probably domestic abuse so it it
probably was a criminal thing I don't
think we had anything to do with uh what
we talked we're addressing here what is
his parental rights and things of that
Family Court yeah that was okay okay
thank you
anyone else representative Raymond
uh thank you I just wanted to say that
um I agree with my colleague
representative Nelson and her concerns
about this bill I think that the intent
is well-meaning but I just don't think
we've got to play out the string
the motion before us is autopath uh the
amendment 771
um
moved out to pass by m Pearson and
seconded by S Pearson
Jim and Pearson
yes
representative long no
representative DeSimone
regrettably no
representative gagne yes
representative Nelson
no
representative McMahon yes
representative ball no
representative Panic yes
representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque
no representative Petrino will be voting
no representative Perez no
representative Greg no representative
Moulton no
now we're back to the original Bell
House Bill 438 the chair will entertain
he really will
don't make me sing That's Entertainment
representative Raymond I think that
given our time limit everyone's like oh
can I write a thing up in five minutes
um but I will make a motion itl
representative Raymond moves itl
and who will second who doesn't have to
write anything representative Greg
any further discussion
when a the clerk is ready please call
the roll the motion before us is itl on
Jim and Pearson
yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone
yes representative gagne yes
representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Stephen Pearson
yes representative Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
yes representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes 16 years
and I would say to anybody in the
audience who had worked on this bill
you've heard the testimony
you've heard the testimony and perhaps
that might inform uh submitting this in
a couple of years is the is there any
okay good thank you
um and representative Raymond for the
blurb
this concludes uh House Bill
438 executive session and I now open
house bill
417 relative to the definition of child
abuse
and this was a bill sent to us I'm
trying to find it uh I have a copy of it
somewhere I'm not sure that I do
I do
uh this was uh representative testerman
is there representative Testament any
amendments or any changes or anything to
it it is as it is
I am
I'm looking for a
motion yes thank you not emotion no okay
um
I would like to make a motion to itl
this bill
I do not believe it's in the appropriate
um area second as child abuse and
representative Petrino seconds it's
um any further any discussion from the
thank you Mr chair um
with all due respect to the
representative who um
sponsored the bill
um because of House Bill 10
I did a lot of research on
um
transgender kids and lgbtq kids
and I I understand through research
exactly how emotional it is for the
parents and the child
if a parent takes a child to a
psychologist or psychiatrist
because they're talking about the fact
that they may be transgender or a member
of the LGBT whatever community and I I
don't mean to throw that off I just
can't keep up with all the letters and
that's no disrespect meant
but if a child goes to a psychologist
with their parent
and the psychologist or psychiatrist
makes recommendations
in the best interest of the child a
loving parent is going to want to follow
those recommendations
a child cannot have lower gender surgery
until the after the age of 18.
I checked with Boston Children's
Hospital and they do not do any of that
gender reassignment surgery
hormonal therapy although it creates
issues but once it's stopped
um it can be reversed
I don't feel that it's right for me to
make a parent of a child who's involved
in this type of an emotional conflict as
well as the rest of the family I don't
think it's right to make the parents a
criminal
so for that reason I support the itl
motion
any further discussion representative
Moulton thank you Mr chairman um I I
appreciate what uh representative
DeSimone had had just mentioned and if
she hadn't mentioned it I would have
already brought it up that
um that this isn't even happening to
kids under 18 they're not having their
gender reassignment however it is
appropriate medical treatment for there
to be hormonal medications for teenagers
whether puberty blockers or hormonal
replacement Therapies
If the child is questioning their the
gender that they were born with so I
personally feel that I should not be
making that decision that should be
between a provider and their patient
like a doctor in their patient
um and not me as a representative so I
any further discussion
um I have to agree I don't think that we
should get involved that in that
discussion I think that should be
between the parent and the child and
deciding what steps to take forward when
they choose to or accept their child the
way that they are and making sure that
they have the right tools to help their
child in any way possible for those that
are supportive is the best way that we
can help lower this specifics of suicide
representative panic
thank you for our
um Vice chairman long for allowing me to
ask this question
I got an email from
um Dr Jennifer Smith
and my concern was the use of these
hormone Therapies
on children
ages 10 to 12 years old and I had asked
if these hormone therapies were FDA
approved
and the email that I was that was sent
to me said that the potential harms
versus the benefits allowing the use of
medicine off label in this area of care
so they are using this off label so that
means that
that translates in my mind that
this is an experiment on the children
if you're using some if you're
transitioning these children
off what medications that were not
designed and there's no FDA studies
this is an experiment that has me very
concerned
so
um
the last time they had experiments on
children if I go back to looking at my
history books was during
the Nazis Gene
during World War II
so I think this is Criminal
thank you
Mr chair yes uh representative DeSimone
um unfortunately uh in one respect
you're correct but in another we aren't
you aren't uh the covid vaccine was an
experimental drug that was given to
children and that drug has been found to
be able to uh cause sterilization in
children but it was given to them with
the
um it was not FDA approved
and it was given to them with the
government's
um
consent so and and it was mandated in
some cases so I I just
I don't think that any kid should have
hormonal therapy either but I'm not the
parent of
a child who is transgender and I think
that parent has a right
go ahead okay
um covid was an emergency
so to prescribe a drug an unapproved FDA
drug
on an emergency basis
I think is different than prescribing
hormonal therapy
well
I think that I no no no we we see it two
different ways and we're trying to be
respectful of everybody
um
I don't see it as an emergency like
hovid was
we hear about the suicide maybe you know
the uh the issue with suicides being
very high on the transgender transgender
Community maybe mental health counseling
might be the Avenue and then when
they're 18 years old they may want to
transition over
um
I think to compare it to the coveted
vaccines is
apples to oranges my opinion only thank
you
anyone else wish to speak representative
Perez
but what I understand in in I've been so
involved with the LBGTQ community and
the transgender Community because I want
to have more respect and understanding
what they go through
in some cases it's necessary it's
medical necessary so I don't believe
we're pushing something in people's
bodies but if they probably make the
decision it does what they want to do
for the child that should have the right
representative Nelson
I
this bill is about
um do we believe that this is child
abuse
so I think
um for me
um regardless of what I may think or I
may not think
um transgender hormone therapy puberty
blockers
are used off label but so are extreme
chemotherapy
um
treatments as a last resort for a very
ill child with cancer and we oh we're
not saying that those parents are being
abused I just saw a testimony that
parents are being advised by medical
professionals whether it be their
pediatrician who's seen their child
telling them that this isn't a necessary
Medical
intervention for lack of better terms
and um
for that reason I don't think that that
falls under per um
the definition of child is thank you
representative Moulton
thank you Mr chairman
um it seems like there's a discrepancy
between what the understanding of
off-label
usage of medications are for it's not
it's not like an experiment they have
studies that back this up for example
Lamictal is used as an anti-seizure
medication it can also be off label use
for mood stabilization okay there's a
lot of different medications that are
used in the medical field off label
but it's not that they don't know what
the expected response is they're still
studies
about them so
to make a broad generalization that
off-label use is an experiment is an
extreme
conclusion
um because that's just not that's just
not the case
thank you
uh this is consistent your statement is
consistent with what the medical staff
at the medical center of which I'm CEO
has told me my concern is surgery
the motion before us on House Bill 417
FN relative to the definition of child
abuse moved by representative Ball itl
seconded by representative Petrino
um the a clerk when ready will call the
roll please the motion is i t l
chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes
representative DeSimone yes
yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes
representative Stephen Pearson yes
representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond yes that would be
16 yes any objection to consents
representative Ball please write the
blurb now I might suggest and this is a
general statement that I make as you
know about every other time we're
together
bills are sometimes rise and fall on how
the prime sponsor presents the bill to
the hearing
and who brings relevant information to
other people and answers and anticipates
and answers questions I think there's
something in this bill that appeals to
me but absent all of those things I had
this concludes the hearing on 4 17. wow
look at this
meet burrow and on time
not not terribly neat but I tried to
make it legible
we'll talk about the use of the comma at
another time
if in doubt put them in
okay that is 417 uh and now 475 we can
exactly I open the exact session on 475
and representative posts you may come up
because you have that
fresh off the press be careful when you
touch it it's hot amendment 10 16.
I know
so if you don't have enough if I didn't
divvy them up enough representative post
please tell us what your Amendment does
okay so thank you very much
um for allowing me to present this I
thank the chairman and the committee
um
do I need to do for the record I only
supposed
I am Lisa post from lineborough I'm a
representative
um so
what we did was we simplified it
um and so uh
it is still the right to pres present
evidence and testimony
and
the parties in any family court
proceeding shall have the right to
present the evidence and testimony
but the change is the presiding judge
magistrate or meritable marital Master
shall follow the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence when admitting such evidence
and testimony this right shall not be
limited by the rules of the Circuit
Court Family Division if for any reason
evidence or testimony is not admitted
the reason shall be noted in the record
which in the note noted being noted in
the record is just simply they've noted
so what I think this does is this allows
the parties to present it
and follow the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence when admitting such and I was
just made aware that there is a bill
that you have to hear
Rules of Evidence is that correct I
think so
so I don't know how that will affect
this
um but
um
I think this is a better bill this way
because it allows
um the court to make those decisions on
their own now this begs the question
what is the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence what are they for Circuit Court
I'm not asking you it's a rhetorical
question right because somebody could
look at it and say wait a minute I've
watched 52 episodes of Law and Order and
that's not how they behaved number one
that's TV and number two that's Criminal
Court I don't think people who object
that the Rules of Evidence are not being
followed always know what they are they
may well be followed you just didn't
like how it broke your way
so when we talk about the Rules of
Evidence we are not talking about what
we wish they were what we think they are
but what in fact The Rules of Evidence
in New Hampshire Circuit Court are as of
right now
would you agree I I would agree and I
would say the judge magistrate
can always explain what that is when
they're not accepting it right so I
think that it's not your main for
okay seeing none chair will entertain a
motion thank you for the the quick
turnaround on this and
chair would recommend uh emotion from
someone
I know what you're doing
anyone want to make a motion oh gosh
representative fall
your motion is
I'd like to make a motion that we accept
the amendment
okay so we are it's an OTP on House Bill
475 Amendment 1016 and that is
representative ball who who would like
we are doing the amendment who would
like to Second the amendment
representative Raymond while your arm
has appeared I'm having trouble finding
representative D samani so could you
give her a little
you know help
yeah okay you could
no Raising Cane
okay any just any further discussion on
the amendments
any further discussion on the amendment
representative Raymond
um thank you and thank you for indulging
me everyone
um I'm still I was just looking up at
the rules of of evidence
um on Google for New Hampshire
um and it talks about
um offers of proof and testimony and you
know being the right to being
cross-examined and I'm
unsure about how that will apply and
work in Family Court situations
I because I just don't have the
experience in in divorce matters and
custody matters to really visualize this
so if someone is providing evidence
do they usually get cross-examined in a
divorce case do they usually have the
same burden of proof and divorce as they
would in other court cases will this
affect that and I don't know the answer
and it's freaking me out
attorney head could you speak to that
and you were Consulting with someone
else in the committee so would you ask
attorney had the question please thank
you attorney head could you please
explain a little bit more about the
rules of evidence and how this amendment
will affect Family Court proceedings
that I'm not familiar with like divorce
and custody and so thank you for the
question
um so current practice there's so the
Rules of Evidence are one set of rules
they apply to all courts they apply to
civil cases depending on the Civil Rules
of Evidence really what we're talking
about primarily here
the
um so you can look up The Rules of
Evidence there are a lot of them they're
complicated and I went to law school and
I still screwed them up once in a while
but the current Rule and family division
is Rule 2.2 which says that
um
New Hampshire Rules of Evidence do not
apply to the actions listed above we're
talking generally about Family Division
and those however the court at its
discretion May utilize The Rules of
Evidence to enhance predictable orderly
fair and reliable presentation of
evidence
one thing to understand about the Rules
of Evidence in terms of thinking about
them sort of generally is they are an
exclusionary
set of rules they they decide what is or
more importantly what is not being
admitted
so if for example somebody says
my soon to be ex-spouse told me that
they were going to pick up my child
that is technically hearsay
um and and then it gets into why is that
if if you're going to try to apply the
Rules of Evidence
at a very technical level require that
the Rules of Evidence be applied
then evidence which today under the
current process could be introduced
might very well get excluded because
Rules of Evidence tend to be an
exclusionary set of rules they decide
essentially you didn't follow all the
steps so we're going to keep that from
getting in
which is sort of contrary to what the
original sort of intent of this bill is
which is trying to get more stuff in
um but that said you also then add to
that the layer of
yes the judge can explain why the rule
of evidence would exclude this piece of
evidence
but now that person is stuck they're in
trial they don't have another shot at
this they're in the proceeding so they
may have understood coming in that this
get introduced but because of the strict
adherence to The Rules of Evidence it
may be excluded as a result
so you know
and we're talking you know relevance
hearsay character if if for example in
the hearsay example my soon-to-be
ex-spouse said that they were going to
the school to pick up my child if it's
being introduced for the truth of the
matter asserted which is the language in
the rule if it's being introduced
because the judge that person wants to
know wants the judge to know that the
ex-spouse is went to the school to pick
up the child that's hearsay it should be
excluded if they are introducing it to
say as a result of hearing that I went
to the school also it technically is not
being introduced for the truth of the
matter asserted the ability the
likelihood that a person who's not
appearing in court who may have
you know limited education has no
experience with the Rules of Evidence
may have mental health issues because
again vast majority of people in these
cases are not represented
that's a kind of a subtle distinction as
to what whether or not they're trying to
introduce it for the truth of the matter
asserted
today under the current process if in
order to ensure a predictable orderly
and reliable presentation of of evidence
the judge can have some discretion
that's what we have today if you apply
the rule strictly you're you're you're
applying exclusionary rules strictly
against parties who may not understand
them
I may have answered your question
a brief follow-up and a brief answer
please
in fact dcyf cases as written this
amendment
dcif cases in Family Division yes okay
okay
I do yes representative ball sorry thank
you chairman thank you for taking my
question so I'm still left a little bit
unsure of I understand that you're
saying because of limited education or
limited health or whatever
um
and you had brought up wealth and all of
those other things but I'm still
if you have one party with
representation in one party without then
you still have an un you still have an
imbalance there so how does the party
um
without the Savvy attorney who knows how
to get evidence in through testimony
how do those people ever get their voice
heard if they can't present the evidence
even if they do it maybe it wasn't done
correctly or maybe the the court could
help guide them and how to get their
evidence in there
how do we balance out that imbalance
so thank you for the question one the
court really can't help somebody
improve their case they can't say how to
introduce evidence they can talk
generally about sort of what it is they
should do but not help them prove their
case in terms of this amendment you were
actually shifting that imbalance in
favor of represented parties because the
only if you have a an attorney and a pro
se party that attorney is going to have
a much better understanding of the rules
of evidence and have the opportunity
to know when to object what to object to
what the rule is going to be and is more
likely to be able to exclude the
information that somebody is trying to
introduce who's not represented has
never experienced The Rules of Evidence
and is is really just there to try to
explain their case
um by by whatever information is
available to them so I think you are
actually
shifting that that power
towards the represented party who may be
wealthier because they can afford the
attorney and what have you so I think
this actually shifts it in that
direction even more
follow up thank you and maybe this is
going toward why we need that house
resolution
um
and help me understand this it's my
understanding that there are people in
the courthouse that help
people get through paperwork and they
have support systems within the
courthouse
um so my question is
wouldn't it be helpful for those people
who don't have representation to have
available to them someone who could help
guide them in how to get evidence in or
before they walk into the courtroom
um so thank you for the question so
there are certain types of cases
domestic violence um some others where
where there are folks on staff who who
assist in in some of the work not the
hearing process but the in the petition
um it doesn't apply to all cases uh and
we simply don't have resources if
nothing else to do that
we have to be you know as the court we
have to be the neutral party
um in terms of information coming to us
we don't
sort of help develop evidence we don't
tell them tell parties how to give us
information how to present evidence
because they get to decide on their own
how they're going to be presenting
evidence once we get into that role of
advocate essentially for a party we're
no longer uh we we sort of step away
from being a neutral body
um you know we're as a court the parties
are
come before the court to present their
evidence and their facts and then the
court has to make a decision and if
we're now assisting one party to get
their evidence in we are now sort of
shifting that that neutrality a little
bit attorney head wouldn't this be a
testimony as to unfortunately it's
expensive but this is why if you go in
uh per se you are putting yourself
perhaps in an advantage a disadvantage
against someone with a lawyer
you know I've seen a lot of pro se
people beat lawyers too so
um it certainly does have a lot of other
work lawyers too would it also be a case
where somebody could go to Legal Aid and
say I've got a case would you take my
case you know but certainly there are
Services
um available what resources are
available I don't know but yes
I think anything else folks
it's the room deadline so I'm sorry just
one other question if evidence how does
this play into like requests for a gal
to get a guardian ad litem if we were
allowed to bring evidence in rather than
going it does its impact that at all
as written doesn't change the guardian
advice process the guardian ad litem
process is sort of a tool to to sort of
gather evidence and present it to the
court
um
and you know it it provides sort of
information to the court that the
parties may have difficulty bringing to
the to the judge so as as written at
least this bill to my mind would not
change the guardian Adeline process
in terms of definition of Rules of
Evidence does that include and the
customary way in which the rules are
evidenced are at the discretion of the
judge
done there's that is discretion built
into Rules of Evidence itself or not
some rules yes okay so it would depend
on the particular Rule and the
circumstance so the Rules of Evidence
could have built-in discretionary power
to the judge
some of them do okay
so this would only change those seek to
change those who which do not
this would require the judge to follow
explicitly without
without deviating from the what's in the
rule
um but but follow it explicitly so the
rule does not contain a carve out for
some some broader
um uh
discretion than no and should this be
signed into law
could the Judiciary then change the
Rules of Evidence accordingly so it
would both be in obedience to this law
but wiser in the eyes of the Judiciary
as to how to do it in other words could
um
that was not a suggestion it was no and
and the problem is you know when when
you have that that waiver sort of
discretionary option it has a standard
built into it also
um so you could build more into them if
you choose you're starting to build upon
build when sort of the current process
is designed for unrepresented parties
primarily to be able to get information
before the judge that that is making a
decision
thank you
representative Moulton thank you Mr
chairman so generally speaking
are you for this or against this
um so thank you for the question we
would we would not support the bill as
written or the amendment is written
thank you
anyone else
the motion before us I apologize I have
to go to Senate Finance I'll come back
with it give them my love I will thank
you uh nope thank you asked him an
expert question on that I've asked you
questions about the amendment
um we now move to the fact that it is
the motion before us is auto pass House
Bill 475 Amendment 1016 H moved by
representative ball and seconded by
representative D Simone the clerkman
called the roll please
voting on the amendment
chairman Pearson no
representative long no representative
DeSimone
representative Dr Simone
Representative gagne no representative
Nelson
no representative McMahon no
representative panic
I'm going with the committee and say no
as well representative Stephen Pearson
no
representative Grossman
no representative Levesque no
representative Petrino will be voting no
representative Perez
no representative Greg no representative
Moulton no representative Raymond
zero years and 16 Nays okay now the
chair will entertain an additional
motion we have to have a positive motion
that passes
not on an amendment
that's on the amendment I'm sorry of
course
thank you everyone
um
I'd like to say I knew that but I was
just testing you but you can see right
through that we are now back to the
original House Bill 475 and we'll take a
motion
representative ball thank you chairman
Pearson
um being new at this I will have to ask
but is it appropriate may I make an um
a motion to retain it is appropriate
and in fact given the testimony and uh
we have heard it is possible that over
the ensuing months the prime sponsor and
others behind this could converse with
the Judiciary and like with the other
bills find ways it squares the circle so
the motion is to retain representative
ball any second on this representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman I second
any further discussion
seeing none watching the clock the a
clerk may call the role when he or she
is ready
chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
DeSimone
yes representative gagne yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yeah representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Stephen Pearson yes representative
Grossman
yes representative Levesque yes
representative Petrina will be voting
yes representative Perez no
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes
representative Raymond
yes 15 yay one nay and the bill is
retained and the good news about a bill
that's retained is what
nobody's got to write a blurb so not
until we're done with it this fall that
ends the exact session on 475 and now
now I'm going to open the exact session
on houseboat 618 relative to wage
garnishment with child support payments
and representatives for Lane
um brought forth an amendment to having
and we'll see if the amendment
um
oh
and I will present the amendment as a
and when you have it all I can point out
if you get out the original Bill 618 FN
and do side by side with the amendment
uh
if you look down on the original Bill
near the bottom you will see in
parentheses the number four and it says
when an average period amounting to the
support owed for two months or more has
accrued we were told in the hearing that
the federal standard is 30 days so on
on the original Bill parentheses 5 if
the obliger resides out of state
we suggested that be removed you will
not see that in the amendment
item on the original Bill the next one
six a court has imposed a protective
order that is in effect and related to
the order of support people ask for that
to be removed as well and it is so
pretty much
everything that
um I think I remember was asked for in
the hearing is addressed in the
amendment so the amendment if it passes
representative long
thank you Mr chairman I know the other
note I took was with respect to uh
uh 21 on the original where the court
system uh where the Division of Child
Support Services shall make the standard
form
and I believe the testimony was that
historically it's the court system that
okay I don't recall that I'm not saying
you're wrong I'm just saying I don't
is that all right yeah I do some child
support here so I
is that child support or am I right now
good afternoon Mr chairman yes uh we did
testify uh the mural child support my
name is attorney Matthew Hayes uh myself
and the director of Child Support
testified on this bill a few weeks ago
uh one of our concerns was this form
that the murals for being asked to
create uh generally the mural
would probably not create a form like
this because every case is so different
from one another
um it's not something I think that we'd
be able to create that would meet every
contingency
um to go to representative Long's point
I think we sent something along those
lines
um
if I if I recall the bill
knew the provisions that would be
requested to be in that form are already
in the uniform support order
in one form or another and then some of
the other provisions
with respect to
to whom uh non-payment is reported
um I think that was one of the issues
something like that's not in the uniform
support order standing orders however if
we're not involved in the case I don't
think that we would be able to provide
anybody with that type of information
we're only involved in cases where
certain benefits are being provided or
I've already applies for our services I
do recall testifying that many cases
that are
many child support cases I'm going to
interrupt you right now because this is
not in the amendment that whole thing
about DHHS child support should
establish a form is not in the amendment
uh well I don't have an amendment in
I beg your pardon sir you may continue
well I don't want to go on too long I
know the committee I respect the
committee's time I mean I suppose
um our position is that we wouldn't feel
like we're the best party to establish a
form like that although I understand
more information uh you know if it's a
matter of working with the judicial
branch to help them streamline whatever
information they do provide there's ways
I think and and certainly providing
parties with more information about our
process if the choose to use our process
I don't see anything wrong with that but
as far as a standard form
I don't know if that is something we
might be able to address
um have you take any questions or
provide my information in case there's
should the bill pass and you're asked to
do this I'm hearing you say there's a
workaround on that DHHS develops a form
which means you Outsource it to the
Judiciary who is more directly involved
and you're happy with that
um or am I reading something in
I don't know if our positions we would
think it's something that would be in a
statute but uh you know it's a policy
decision if the legislature asks us to
do something we can certainly try to
work with the judicial branch the
problem is it's just that
we don't we're only authorized to deal
with certain cases and we don't deal
with divorce cases I I we don't attend
final hearings we don't go to we are not
authorized to appear in Parental actions
it's
merely child support hearings unless you
know if there's a child support case
that's open with our Bureau then we're
allowed you know we're certainly able to
answer parties questions so we go to the
hearings if we need to but
um I I just don't know if we're
comfortable with a blanket form
um
just slips outside the scope of what
we're authorized to do
and yet if this bill passes you are
authorized to do it now
well to the extent that we're authorized
in
under their title 40 in the Social
I should think that authorization to do
something is more determined by the law
that these State puts into effect than
any departmental procedures I think the
problem is is really as I said two of
the pieces are already in the uniform
support order okay and then you get the
piece that says you know we're supposed
to develop a form that says if you're
not getting payment this is what you
should do we wouldn't know in every case
what that person should do if they're
not using our services we don't know
anything about their case Okay
um you know that should be something
that should be left up to their attorney
to help them with or or the court can
say when they're issuing the uniform
support order
this is payable through direct payments
to the parties not the bureau child
support if this person doesn't pay you
final emotional contempt or bring them
back for a payment hearing uh
thank you that's sort of the issue thank
you anyone else with a question
I have not moved this I simply
introduced it so we could look at it
could I have a sense of the room about
whether you like the amendment or not
then I will not move the amendment
and the chair will entertain
emotion
I'll make a motion to retain uh House
Bill 618 please representative D Simone
moves to retain seconded by and there's
no blurb involved no writing
could I say this is the short and the
this will give us a chance to deal with
this question and I hope the supporters
of this representative Edwards being one
of them representative D Simone being
another and and all kinds of good folks
can deal with these little issues to
make this this is an important bill
to to kill
so retaining I believe is the right
motion anybody wish to speak to the
retaining motion
all right then I would quickly just
state that uh I second your statement
that it's a very important bill it needs
to be worked on and that's why I made
the motion
you can start writing the what I did on
my summer vacation script though
ever growing staff
yep alrighty now hearing nothing else
the motion before us is to retain House
Bill 618 FN move by representative the
Simone seconded by representative long
with the assistant clerk please call the
roll chairman Pearson yes
Vice chairman long yes representative
DeSimone yes representative Gagnon gagne
yeah I'm sorry representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Stephen Pearson
yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino yes
representative Perez
no
representative Greg yes representative
Moulton yes representative Raymond yes
that would be 15 years and one day thank
you and this ends House Bill 618 uh
executive session before we do the can
you say last one before us just a
reminder to all Republicans here that we
have a zoom caucus at 6 00 pm tonight
please representative long anything for
your caucus
I'm a main star security is as good as
and in terms of Representative gagne and
Petrino and and so on
um
for the record I pronounced my last name
England
okay
Nelson Raymond yeah
open the executive session on House Bill
499 uh relative to the admission of
certain evidence in Family Court
proceedings
um
I don't know do we have an amendment
anywhere
anybody look through your book to see if
we were given an amendment a while ago
and
uh Mr chairman if I may we do we have
so
um
I don't
see my assistant
um research assistant or committee
assistant
I don't have any other amendment I only
have 619 does anybody else have another
amendment than 619
it sure does look familiar stuff done
that doesn't look like something we just
did a few minutes ago
Rules of Evidence I mean I'm 73 74 next
month and my short-term memory is pretty
210 all right I'll be with you stalled
them
this is House Bill 499 the amendment is
619.
and we have been handed it out
previously
thank you
the operative part of the amendment is
line 14 of it if the judge has reason to
believe that applying the Rules of
Evidence shall adversely affect the case
the judge May waive the Rules of
Evidence with the kind of statement
above otherwise you don't
um
were you just waving
you weren't even waving you were just
gesture it you were talking hanging out
hanging out with your peeps okay got it
all right
um my opinion is that this is saddon
close to what we've just retained that
we can retain this at the same time what
do you think
well what representative Nelson
thank you Mr chairman
um I don't want to do that with haste
though
um so we can if we retain both of them
we could then study the wording and
verbiage of each and also too remember
we're going to have that um orientation
on the 28th which might be helpful for
us too so I I just I I agree with you
that retaining might be
um more beneficial I I have seen in a
retained session two bills brought up
simultaneously and dealt with together
uh representative Perez Mr chairman now
you told me that my back my summer
vacation is going to be reminded
that we've retaining all these bills and
we're gonna have to be here all summer
long no that was a joke
um English humor is difficult to acquire
sometimes um we we're funny even no I'm
just trying to be funny as well okay
well thank you for that appreciate that
um we're going to work on them in
September and October which doesn't mean
individuals can't group themselves as
they wish to work on them during the
summer I probably won't be in many of
those groups but we will deal with them
in September and October so another hand
up
representative disamani uh is it too
early to make a motion Mr chairman
it depends what your motion is my motion
is to retain you may make that motion
so moved and who would like to second
that from the other playground it is the
some of my best friends
as representative Raymond okay any
further discussion
Mr chairman I just want to make it clear
that this is on the amendment or this is
on the bill the amendment has not been
presented correct thank you it's on it
has been given to us it was not
presented a member of the committee
needs to remember the committee is
the motion before us is on the bill zero
six no it isn't it is on the bill 499 F
and the motion is to retain move by
representative DeSimone
seconded by representative Raymond would
the clerk please call the roll
chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes the
representative DeSimone yes
representative gagne yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative Stephen Pearson
yes representative Grossman yes
representative Levesque yes
representative Petrino will be voting
no representative Greg yes
representative Moulton yes
representative Raymond
yes motion to retain
15-15-1 the motion to retain passes 15-1
there is no blurb required
um other than me who's going over to
finance three to testify in two minutes
Mr chair
what
I really don't know what I'm going to be
an expert about I'll just Bluff with him
go ahead I would just like to remind the
committee that today is not bring your
kid to work day and I did volunteer to
be as a sub here today is bring your kid
to work day right kid
is today bring your kid to work day it
is bring your kid to work day there's
another kid brought to work right there
thank you everybody
um if you have to write a blurb other
than me who will write it as soon as I'm
done next door uh please get it done
hand it to the clerk
if the clerk is not in this room because
others are in this room you will be in
the office there yeah take my desk I've